et on parle justice à présent après
trois semaines de procès l'ancien chargé
de mission de l'elysée alexandre benalla
sera fixé sur son sort ce sera le 5
novembre prochain jugement en délibéré y
sont et l'ancien proche collaborateur de
d'emmanuel macron a comparu pour douze
infractions notamment pour violences en
réunion et miction dans la fonction de
policier lors de la fête du travail
c'était le 1er mai 2018 le parquet de
paris qui a requis à la fin de la
semaine dernière justement 18 mois de
prison avec sursis 500 euros d'amendé
cinq ans d'interdiction de toute
fonction publique et dix ans
d'interdiction de port d'armes pour en
parler pour faire le point justement de
ce procès on va retrouver celle farges
devant un tribunal judiciaire de passe
[Musique]
bonjour estelle alors des dites nous
quels sont les chefs d'accusation
concernant alexandre benalla
et bien olivier alexandre benalla a
comparu pour douze infractions au
premier chef pour violences en réunion
et immixtion dans la fonction de
policier chez l'ex collaborateur à des
manuels macron est aussi soupçonné
d'avoir utilisé frauduleusement
ces passeports diplomatiques et d'avoir
aussi obtenu un passeport de service
grâce à un faux ainsi que d'avoir porté
une arme sans autorisation en 2017
pendant la campagne du chef de l'état le
parquet a donc requis à 18 mois de
prison avec sursis à son encontre 500
euros d'amendé et cinq ans
d'interdiction de toute fonction
publique et 10 ans est d'interdiction de
port d'armes est l alexandre benalla qui
a déclaré aussi avoir voulu bien faire
lors de ces évènements du premier mais
qu'a t'il déclaré précisément
exactement j'ai eu une volonté de rendre
service d'être au service mais je ne me
suis jamais servi a déclaré alexandre
benalla il a reconnu une erreur de
jugement alors comme depuis le début si
la défense a soutenu qu alexandre
benalla n'avait pas commis a de violence
le 1er mai à 2018 notamment au jardin à
des plantées sur la place de la
contrescarpe mais qu'il avait aidé à
l'interpellation d'individus en flagrant
délit comme la loi l'autorisé appelant
le tribunal à se départir du raz de
marée médiatique la défense a donc
plaidé la relaxe pour toutes les
poursuites sauf pour l'utilisation des
passeports diplomatiques un fait
qu'alexandre benalla à d'ailleurs
reconnu lors de son éviction de l'elysée
le verdict est donc attendu dans un mois
le 5 novembre précisément merci beaucoup
estelle pour toutes ces précisions
estelle farges en direct devant le
tribunal judiciaire de paris